Film Courage: We have this amazing game called The
Story Engine and that's going to help us generate
an idea. We're going to use your tools to develop
the idea into a movie. We'll start by drawing a
card, there are different cards. The first one is
the agent card, presumably that's the protagonist
Jeff Kitchen, Dramatist /
Author / Founder / Consultant:
We have an automaton, a machine, a
puppet and a servant. Interesting.
Film Courage: Of the four, which one do you
think would be the best to build a story around?
Jeff: Well an automaton is certainly timely
and it is a machine and it can be a puppet in
certain ways and it can be certainly a servant
so it encompasses a lot of those elements and
yet is still open-ended and very much of today.
Film Courage: Which of the four do you think
would actually make the least interesting story?
Jeff: I don't know because there's
really infinite variables in each one
so whereas one might think a puppet or a
servant would naturally appear less interesting,
there's so much potential nuance and a
servant often has much more capability
and sort of behind the scenes facility
and power then they might appear at first.
Puppets have been used in varying ways where they
can be brilliant and unexpected and unpredictable
or treacherous and there's a really full
spectrum potential in that too a machine
sounds more inert because a coffee grinder
is a machine so that might be the least
the least my brain is not exploding with
possibilities when I look at machine whereas with
each of the other ones it just starts going my
brain is just going yeah yeah lots lots this right
direction just sort of all over the place of of a
very full spectrum of possibilities for each one
okay I mean so we have a servant puppet and do
you have a a choice of one I mean you could be an
inanimate object or it could be a political puppet
it could be a servant who works in a wealthy
person's home or it could be a civil servant it
could be different types of we can choose from
many different ways but well the automaton
is the one that I think grabs me the most
because it is timely and it is a kind of a puppet
and is a kind of a servant so it encompasses
though and it is a machine it encompasses
all of them in a rather rather universal way
and yet with the onset of AI and Elon Musk's
automaton and robots in just the general fear
of robots and the astonishing potential
inherent in them it's a rich arena that is
very open-ended and kind of very chemically active
in my brain before I even start poking it okay so
it sounds like that will be our protagonist then
yeah Thomas okay okay now the next step would be
to draw an engine card all right so we have wants
to stop the theft of wants to steal or steal from
okay which scenario do you like the best
steel is for me more open-ended
because to stop the theft of
feels more like a normal daily
function like a good servant
would naturally be trying to
stop the theft of something
and so to steal from there's it's it's a less
predictable type of automaton the reasoning of
why this automaton is trying to steal something
all the mechanics of that all the what's the
word for it the pre-programming that might have a
have a type of prohibitive effect on the automaton
so that the automatons like going against
internal commands or something to achieve that
there's just it's
feels a little more dynamic okay it's an
open-ended if you had to play the other scenario
how do you think you would weave that in
with this automaton well it's there's a
full spectrum full spectrum of possibilities
in terms of preventing the theft of what
so it could be preventing the theft of a
nuclear weapon that could end the world
or blow up the Eastern Seaboard of
America or something or it could be
you know to prevent the theft of an important
artifact something of personal value so it's
like on the other end of the spectrum
and then there's everything in between of
the theft of something that will severely
disrupt an ongoing successful operation or
the theft of something with tremendous emotional
power that can really disrupt something and
it's really just a matter of like what you
set the dial to the intensity the stakes
is going to motivate the way in which
this automaton works to prevent the theft
excellent so it could be riveting from
beginning to end because the whole fate
of the world hangs on it or it could be
intensely personal and it's making sure
this kid's doll doesn't get taken because that's
the end of the universe for that particular kid
so you just find the context and then find
a way to give it magnitude make it matter to
the audience and some of them are naturally
more nail biting than others and what if we
had to choose both what if we incorporated both
scenarios well that's a nice complication because
it's like a crooked cop where you're I'm here
guarding the the whatever and while I'm doing
that I'm busy working the yeah working the back
doors to steal something much bigger in the museum
that I'm now guarding or something there's
all those kind of tunnels under tunnels and
how do you disguise what you're up to and is
the theft from good intention or evil intention
you can be stealing something that unless
you steal it there will be a lot of trouble
excellent okay okay so now we have the anchor
card and if you would do us the honor progressive
choosing anchor card love how this
is going excited to see how it
turns out all right so we have a hospital,
a contagion, a medicine, a death.
Which one of these would make
the most sense in the story
a contagion is timely with covid but
people might kind of have covid fatigue
kind of sick of hearing about
it but generally you don't write
many people suggest not writing about topical
events because quite soon they're yesterday's
news and whereas right now you could go
oh this will you can amplify this into
something but people may be so sick of it
or not care about it six months from now
so the topical the topicality of it sets
off an alarm Bell in my brain because I
haven't kind of been trained for that go for
something that's still Universal a thousand
years from now rather than it's forgotten
about in six weeks a medicine is interesting
because that can really be world changing
and not only that but but it's the there's
a huge amount of money in that field
they used that well in the Harrison Ford
movie The Fugitive where the Provasic was a
medicine whose lab tests were falsified
so they could make big money on it a death
but death is certainly interesting there
can be high stakes there or there can be no
stakes there like why does nobody care that
this person died how come like it doesn't
bleep the radar at all or it can be the
death can be world changing and it can be
an impending death a sudden death a death that
happened 40 years ago a death that happened
last night a death that's been threatened
so there's there's broad flexibility in
each one of these things like and I talk
to my students about this that as we're
building a script I'm always talking about how
you want to be make tentative decisions and
be plastic as a habit of mind so that everything
everything stays fluid as long as possible
because then you're not just go okay it's got
to be this it's much better to be well it's
kind of that and then as you work with it more
you're refine it a little bit more and you're
constantly grooming it and shaping it how you want
so when I look at something like this I don't just
see one thing I see like five or six different
possibilities all clustered together as variables
and I can really I'm trained for that it's like
a juggler you can just a skilled juggler can be
like watching the news and they don't miss a
ball so like I can I'm good at holding four or
five possibilities in solution as options okay so
we're in a hospital was the fourth ah okay yeah so
no one's contagion possibly the death death is
interesting medicine is extremely interesting.
Hospital is interesting it's a whole universe unto
itself I come from a family of doctors I grew up
around hospitals and hospitals a lot of people die
in hospitals so they can get a bad rep but a lot
of people get saved there a lot of people get born
there so even though it's easy to associate them
with failure and loss there's also a huge element
of regeneration and the gift of life and all of a
sudden you're going to live 50 more years when you
might have died that afternoon that kind of thing
it doesn't fascinate me as much as a medicine for
instance the hospital is an interesting setting
and has a lot of possibilities
but it's finite in a certain way
medicine I think a medicine is the most
interesting and a death is the second most
interesting okay but a death is cool because it
really is it brings in the whole the element of
like a murder mystery or that kind of thing it
it like opens another whole hallway full of doors
as possibilities okay great so now
what we'll do is inject conflict
okay and so we will draw a conflict card all right
foreign we have two here but the innocent
will suffer but it means giving up their dream
interesting do automatons Dream of Electric
Sheep when Philip K dick wrote Do Androids
Dream of Electric Sheep I don't know maybe
1968 I don't remember the date but it was
not current AI capabilities even though he's a
science fiction writer and he's seeing into that
but we're these things are actually real now
so the science fiction authors are kind of like
working with what we have now and then
projecting into the future from that
and so the idea that an Android might have to
give up its dream that's really interesting
and they just said they think they they the
spiders dream that's been on the internet lately
I don't I mean it seems like our dog dreams when
he's like he's running and barking and things and
so that's really interesting but the innocent
will suffer yeah that's interesting too
and that also speaks to the
the programming that's not the right word the
laws of robotics which goes back to Isaac Asimov
I don't remember the verbatim but
you will never harm a human being
or you will never allow a harm human
being to be harmed by your inaction
I don't remember the other ones but the one of the
things that I use in my class constantly in terms
of working with dilemma and illustrating someone
trapped in a dilemma is Robbie the robot from
the movie Forbidden Planet 1956 or something like
that which has Leslie Adams in it the comedian
and he's playing a serious space investigator
a space man and they're going to a Shipwrecked
it's people who've been Shipwrecked on a planet
there's only two survivors Morbius and his
daughter and Morbius found some alien technology
inside the planet and using that technology built
Robbie the robot who's extremely sophisticated
robot and he's demonstrating Robbie to Commander
Adams the Leslie Nielsen character and he has
Robbie he he has Commander Adams give Robbie the
ray gun he orders Robbie to shoot a tree outside
he does so and then he orders Robbie to point
the gun at Commander Adams who's starting to get
pretty nervous and then he orders Robbie to fire
and Robbie starts short-circuiting he's like
and you can see the sheets of electricity
going up through him and he's like kind
of having a meltdown and Morbius says
Robbie is caught in a dilemma he's been programmed
on one hand to never disobey my orders but he's
also been programmed to never harm a human being
so he says if I leave him like this he'll just
melt down he's literally his core will melt
because his computer cannot send a command
in either direction so he releases him from the
command and it's such a great illustration of
someone trapped in a dilemma because if you
have two equally unacceptable alternatives
and and a really obvious one would
be like a Sophie's Choice type
sacrifice one kid or the other she's she
like she doesn't have a gun but she's like
she can't her brain can't send a command in either
direction and you want that even though Sophie's
Sophie's dilemma is not a dilemma the way I teach
it where it encompasses a full proportion of the
script it's more just a story we are told in the
middle of that movie that explains why she's so
upset and kills herself at the end and those kind
of things it's a it's a quick window but that that
illustration of the of the short-circuiting robot
is the kind of thing you want when you create a
dilemma and the innocent will suffer that could
trigger one of the robotic laws that the robot
not like can't allow people to suffer because
that's an unrealistic command because there's
forms of suffering all over the place
constantly a robot couldn't move if it
could never allow suffering it would be swept
up in every single thing that came by him but
there's a certain degree of suffering that
begins to perhaps approach death which might
trigger or activate some of the prohibitions that
are built into this robot if that makes sense
right I think Ursula K Le Guin has a
similar thing about suffering we're
something omelas [The Ones Who Walk Away from
Omelas Narrative by Ursula K. Le Guin] about if
we knew that everything would be okay if one
child though had to suffer and no one would
say anything about it yeah there's there's
some story that she wrote that was right and
there's a lot of moral dilemmas like that if
you can save this train there's 50 people on
it but that means 30 people on this train
will die there's all those types of things
which I thought would be useful in terms of
working with dilemma as a writer they're somewhat
useful but they're so specialized that it's kind
of like one one aspect of studying dilemma which
hasn't been as useful as I thought it would be
and so I know of it but I don't mine it a lot.